what's up
guys bang bang it is lunch money time
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with paulina i don't know what
this is it's like an easter
slash a little bunny outfit whatever is
going on is going on
polina was famous in bulgaria today
she's literally giving interviews in
bulgarian
i'm like i don't know how to speak
bulgarian but that's okay
what is going on not too much i was
really nervous because
i realized in the middle of the
interview that i actually
don't know how to speak bulgaria oh
don't forget
lunch money is not sponsored by block
five block by has three products they've
got
a crypto exchange where you can buy it
so crypto you can earn up to eight point
six percent apy in an interest bearing
account
and you can deposit crypto take out a
usd
loan against your crypto collateral
let's get it go to block fight.com
pomp are they capitulating
ready me say my piece
jp morgan said bitcoin could rally as
high as 146
000 in the long term as it competes with
gold
as an alternative currency yeah
alternative currency
bitcoin's volatility would need to drop
substantiate before it can match gold
blah blah blah
jp morgan ceo jamie dimon once called
bitcoin
a fraud and said he is more interested
in blockchain technology than crypto
what do you have to say why are they so
conservative
146 thousand dollars so why so exact
let me be very clear here bitcoin market
cap will surpass
gold's market cap by the end of this
decade decade yes
bitcoin today's about a 600 billion
dollar market cap gold's anywhere
between eight to nine trillion depending
on who you talk to
bitcoins market cap will surpass gold's
market cap by the end of this year
why it is because both of them are sound
money principles
one is an analog application of it
meaning that it is shown in physical
form it's sound money principles in a
physical form analog version
bitcoin is sound money principles in a
digital
application everything in the world
if you have the analog version or the
physical version and then you digitize
it
the digital version is always bigger
than the physical version
why because of accessibility and
technology adoption
so bitcoin will eventually grow to be
bigger than gold i believe
that will happen by the end of this
decade jp morgan saying it's gonna be
worth 146 thousand dollars
is going to look overly conservative
by the end of this decade because what
people around the world are realizing
is that the fiat currencies are being
devalued away
about 30 percent of all u.s dollars in
circulation
have been put there in the last 12
months 30 percent of all the dollars in
circulation have been created in the
last 12 months
if you think that this is sustainable
you've lost your mind
if you think that the cost of assets and
the cost of goods
isn't going to explode especially for
the bottom 40
of americans you've lost your mind and
so what happens is people say i need
help i need
something to protect my wealth and they
go and they get bitcoin
not gold and so we've seen outflows from
the gold etfs we've seen inflows to the
bitcoin
uh publicly traded funds that will
continue institutions want bitcoin
bitcoiners aren't selling and so the
price has to aggressively go up
in order for it to accommodate everyone
your face looks perfectly oval today
because i got that
i got that big brain i don't think
that's what it makes it
actually having a small brain means that
you're smarter than if you have a big
brain it's how many wrinkles you got on
the brain
facts that's what you guys watch live
agree on something
well it's just science billionaire
investor carl
icahn warned of the possibility of
significant dil
decline for stocks at some point okay i
could have told you that you didn't need
to listen to carl icon there there will
be
a significant decline in stocks at some
point he said in my day
i've seen a lot of wild rallies with a
lot of mispriced stocks but there's one
thing they all have in common
eventually they hit a wall and go into a
major painful correction
nobody can predict when it will happen
but when that does happen
look out below okay now
this is can i can i say this is just
very generic
no what he's saying is he's saying look
there's been this massive rally that
stocks are
overvalued by all the value uh investor
metrics the two things that i will say
is they've been saying the same thing
about amazon for 20 years and the value
investors have to realize that
technology companies
have a very deflationary impact on a
market so that drives down prices it
drives down the cost of labor it drives
all this stuff down
it is different in terms of the types of
businesses the multiples
are different for a reason nobody would
have thought you could build
a trillion dollar company in the old
world without
uh kind of this internet enabled
technology so maybe they are
valued just fine then second point
is that you've got market manipulation
going on the federal reserve
literally took out the bazooka it was
like
and they just sent trillions of dollars
into the economy
they're just literally stuffing the
economy and it's all relative because
it's not just the us economy
they're doing this everywhere around the
world central banks are just literally
printing and printing and printing money
putting into the economy it
devalues currencies and when you devalue
the currency the price of things go
up so the stock market looks like it's
continuing to rise
if you take the stock market and you
denominate it in
gold since 1971 the stock market is down
so it is the dollar that is being
devalued more so than it is value being
so it's kind of like a fake like
the u.s stock market has not kept up
with the price appreciation
of gold that's crazy so
again it looks like this line straight
up into the right a 45 degree angle
inflation guys don't
forget inflation yes i'm just here to
remind people of the inflation
yeah and you've got all kinds of wackos
on the internet that are saying that
inflation's two percent if you think
inflation is two percent
i got all kinds of things to say i got
chucky cheese coins to sell all right
all right next are you okay yeah i'm
great okay i'm just real fired up today
i had some idiot who's in a very very
influential position
write me an email today and he couldn't
have been more wrong and i had to let
him know all right
you let him know i told him he was a cog
in the wheel of the incumbents that was
right for disruption
a direct quote i literally wrote that
and like this person is pretty uh this
person doesn't get emails like that
every day but i had to let them know
just
put you on notice disruption is coming
and you're
sitting in an institution we got dancing
robots now
all right um jack ma where
is jack ma they found them
they found them supposedly they found
them they found it supposedly they are
claiming that uh he's just laying low
he's not he didn't disappear he was like
oh
he hasn't done any public appearances
lately yeah
if i was jack ma i'd chill in my bed i
wouldn't go out the door i'm famous
enough i don't need to be on your public
appearance
that's all i have to say yeah cool until
the ccp comes and says we're going to
re-educate you jack ma you think you're
a billionaire
they ain't coming though for him they
absolutely came for him they stopped him
from going public
oh yeah that's right yeah and then he
and then he wasn't seen for too much
well if you're gonna stop me from being
public i'm gonna chill at home and not
go out in public
uh maybe that's what happened or okay
janet
just can we say one thing though can we
just bring up one point this is
important are we gonna have to redo the
video
no no no no just just give me permission
to say my point
go on this is why america is the
greatest country in the world
because we have capitalism and democracy
well you can you have freedom of speech
you have freedom of speech you can say
whatever you want you can literally
say whatever you want until i cut the
video and i'm like you're not saying
that but that's
the michael jackson joke was oh it was
not guys
there were better jokes in the comments
that i saw than his joke
the michael jackson joke was all time
kids cover your ears i'll say it one
time
go ahead just kidding
janet yellen president-elect joe biden's
pick for treasury secretary made more
than
seven million dollars in recent years by
giving speeches to the wall street
banks to wall street banks major
corporations and industry groups
the people that she wants to regulate
she made seven
million dollars off of them hey
who you think's sad she's on
but she'll soon regulate them by the way
i have no problem
with her once she left going and doing
speeches and getting paid lots of money
she's smart she's got something to say
they want to hear it great
you should be able to earn as much money
as you want wow she made
she made 952 thousand dollars
from speeches to city you think city's
gonna get the largest banks in the
country
you think city's gonna be uh treated
nicely when uh she's the treasury
secretary
i don't know but uh i got 952 000
reasons to believe that maybe she might
treat them pretty nicely
so now people are concerned about her
cozy relationship with wall street
meanwhile i'm like why people paying me
a million dollars to give a speech do
you know the kind of speech i can give
well they didn't pay a million dollars
for one speech okay
nobody's paying me a million dollars
from multiple students let me give you a
bitcoin to give a speech
sure all right well that's too high at
the price
the second thing to think about is uh
speaking of inflation janet yellen is
famous famous for thinking that it's
okay to let inflation run higher
uh and to basically just be real real uh
liquid with the cash juice with the cash
not real liquid
and so uh we're setting up for an
absolute destruction of the purchasing
power of the us dollar
we got joe biden and kamala harris who
literally
are like oh that 900 billion that we
just approved that was a down payment
we're coming in with 3.3 trillion get
the bazooka ready
and then you got janet yellen who is
notorious for being okay with
degrading the purchasing power and
increasing higher levels of inflation
these people are about to conspire
to do this and you're going to sit there
and you're going to watch it and they're
going to absolutely destroy the
purchasing power of the us dollar
and they are going to destroy the middle
class
hurt the bottom 50 remember yes i read
in this article i found out that she has
a stamp
collection janette yellen does which is
estimated to be worth between fifteen
thousand dollars and
fifty thousand dollars you know about
janet yellen's stamp collection because
i didn't and i want to know more well
one bitcoin's about to be worth more
than her stamp collection so maybe she
should have turned those stamps
in and gotten some bitcoin understand
well we can't equate everything to
bitcoin price now like would you rather
have a stamp or a bitcoin
a stamp collection okay that will
appreciate over time
okay which one would you rather have the
bitcoin
of course and her her stamp collection
if it's only worth fifteen thousand
dollars 250
000. yeah well let's say it's only
fifteen thousand the bottom end of the
range that means that her stamp
collection is worth half a bitcoin
that's a lot james if she had sold her
stamps and bought a bitcoin one
big one's at 15 000. she literally would
have doubled it let's stop being mean to
miss janet by the way she's super smart
i'm just telling you what's coming
is these people are about to destroy the
purchasing power of the us dollars hide
your kids hydro stamp collections
they have to that's pretty good joke uh
they have to do it
because they are addicted they are
interventionist they can't let the free
market run
because they feel like they don't have
control they have to intervene
and they have our economy absolutely
addicted to monetary stimulus go ahead
slack went down
on the first full day of work in 2021
people had to do
work via email they were like oh yes
and horse and boogie you all thought
2020 was bad
watch this oh and then notion went down
too
why do you care three minutes before my
interview and all my interview questions
were saved on notion
and i just had to wing it guys do you
know how not fun that is
and i had a moment of meltdown and he
was like
you have one job which is to interview
people you can interview somebody
without your questions and i was like
you also told me you hate the internet i
i said i hate the internet
all right but by the way this is why
don't write things down who cares about
those just put it in your head
if you have a good memory then you'll
always have it right there in your i
don't have a good memory and i don't
rely on my
memory just remember that i love you
is this the first i love you on lunch
money history i think it is
you owe me a bitcoin for that all right
so we got for us yup we got ask lunch
money time
ask lm in the comments guys i will
answer questions and so will polina
hey guys love the show from diogo do you
invest
if so and what cheers from portugal do i
invest no but i should because all the
investments i would have made
would have exploded you could tell them
what you do uh for the early stage
investing
what i do for them she helps me oh
she meets she meets the founder
sometimes and she tells me yeah
i like this they got good energy they
don't got good energy
a mile away she literally hits me with
they ain't got good energy
what and then am i right you like would
you you're not evaluating crystals
you're looking at people's business and
then am i right
second of all diogo d-i-o-g-o
i learned this recently that is the
proper way
to write the name diego is not
diego you guys are cheating if you're a
diego you should change your name to
diogo where did you learn this
uh uh somebody i know who runs a company
uh their name is
diogo and they were telling they were
explaining it it sounds like
something a diogo would say and i feel
like a diego would say that they are the
real version hey if you diego i can't
help you
diogo's got to me first it's like me
with paulina
p-o-l-i-n-a and p-a-u-l-i-n-a
p-a-u-l-i-n-a
okay this isn't a spelling bee this
isn't a spelling bee okay
next on djs um so he's awesome
he lives in europe he knows a guy i
think he is
he lives in europe lunch money is his
evening dessert because he's in europe
um his question is how exactly does it
work to take out a loan against
bitcoin i mean i don't want to sell it
but i would like to take the profit
someday
pomp and michael saylor have hard-coded
my brain into never sell your bitcoin
at what price range is it safer or
better to take out the loan 100k
a million dollars what are the risks i
guess this way it is tax-free right
thanks keep up the good work you're
awesome you're awesome
okay all right this is not financial
advice i'm merely going to explain how a
loan against bitcoin works basically you
give somebody your bitcoin
they then say okay you gave me a hundred
dollars for the bitcoin i will give you
30
in cash and the reason why it's a great
business for them is because they have
your bitcoin
and if the price goes down right so
meaning that there's risk
they can sell your bitcoin in order to
recoup their 30
so it's a great business for the lender
the reason why people do this
is because they need cash liquidity but
they don't want to sell the bitcoin
because that's a taxable event or they
want to hold it because it's going to
appreciate or whatever
and so what they'll do is they'll give
somebody their bitcoin say i'll give you
a hundred dollars of bitcoin you give me
30
of cash the risk in doing this is if you
say here's my hundred dollars of bitcoin
i got 30 in cash and then the price of
bitcoin falls
all of a sudden they're gonna start
selling your bitcoin at certain marks
in order to make sure they don't lose
the 30 loan so it's
the collateral similar to a car loan if
you stop paying your car loan they come
they repossess your car and then they
liquidate it to recoup their money
don't yawn so what you should do is
if you want to do this you've got to be
very careful you don't want to have
a high ltv media this is not financial
uh you you don't want to go and get
something that's like hey i gave you 100
i'm going to borrow 80 right you want to
keep it low
uh and then the second thing is that
you've got to be really intelligent
about
managing the margin so if all of a
sudden you took a 30
ltb loan i gave 100 bitcoin i got 30 in
cash
and all of a sudden now bitcoins price
drops so my 30
is against only 50 of bitcoin
well that's a big problem so you gotta
either post more collateral et cetera so
long story short is
it's pretty straightforward how it works
it's risky
and so you've got to be very careful do
your own research and go make your own
decisions
don't listen to me i don't know anything
but that's how it works
okay thank you um wj
ebell who is a better dancer palm for
pimp do you even have to ask
by the way that's all you needed that's
all you needed to know
he's actually a pretty good dancer
shockingly pretty good i have never lost
a dance competition ever i've been in a
lot of clubs
i've been in a lot of bars and i've
never lost a single dance competition
and i'll even go as far as i said do you
want to know what the finishing move is
no that if you do it i'm gonna i'm
telling everyone
i got one move it's undefeated i
[ __ ] walk anybody who doesn't know what
a [ __ ] walk is go ahead go google it
i [ __ ] walk on over to whoever i'm
competing with
and i take my shirt and i put it over
their head
undefeated if that happens to you if
somebody [ __ ] walks over to you and then
takes their shirt and puts it over your
head
you got to leave the club like you got
to go
just saying undefeated ask any friend i
have
all right give me your best move right
now that is the move
i i don't even do it like it's not like
i like oh do a bunch of other stuff like
literally i just go right for the kill
shot oh you want to dance okay
it's a hilarious dog yeah it's a
hilarious like you like waddle you're
like
well okay we all know i'm more athletic
all right next um
dan williams would you rather fight one
horse-sized duck or a hundred duck-sized
horses
this is what i'm here for hold on hold
on one horse
one horse-sized duck or a hundred
duck-sized horses
a hundred duck-sized horses wrong
oh but they're like agile and they can
kick you
but if you've got one it's like in a
fight you can fight something bigger
stronger or whatever but it's always
better to have one threat than a hundred
threats if that threat is
massive a horse-sized duck what's that
duck in the door i'll punch that duck
right in his beak
it's gonna literally eat you it's gonna
like
it's gonna pick you up i'm gonna [ __ ]
walk over drop you into a
[ __ ] walk over the duck and put my shirt
over his head it's gonna take you in
and drop you in the ocean with the
sharks that's what the duck
ducks don't go in the ocean like that
yep but it can fly i think
can it fly yeah well yes ducks can fly
okay somebody needs to go back do you
know how
big a duck-sized horses big
yeah you gonna have them going around
they're gonna turn around and kick you
but see i love ducks
okay it's okay okay all right anything
left
anything left no go sign up for a
blockfly account blockfy.com
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends